you still a good gambler are you good or
you get it the cards no I found out a
long time ago I can't win enough to
excite me but I can lose enough to
impress me ain't that the truth
I just don't do it I'm wondering for you
when the time was that you realized that
that you wanted to kind of say farewell
to all of this about a year ago because
my mobility is so bad and it's no fun to
go out there and wrap around how did the
family feel about it when you finally
decided when you when you told them what
was happening what you decide well the
boys are 13 now and they asked me one
day so dad were you gonna do when you
quit singing and said well I don't know
I thought I'd come home and spend all my
time with you guys and they went for me
do you remember the time when you
realize that the reality had become
bigger than the dream see I never
dreamed of being bigger yeah always
dreamed of being happy where I was you
know and I was very lucky because I
didn't set such high standards for
myself that I would be disappointed if I
didn't reach him so that was a great
piece of wisdom well yeah but I mean I
said mediocrity was my head I know oh
well mission failed
I'm afraid yeah well that's it my life
has been so it's kind of like I take
what it's given me and since I didn't
put pressure on myself I think it's
given me much more than I ever dreamed
be good
[Music]
24 number-one hits we've got 80 records
we've got spanning six decades is there
a moment or an opportunity or something
that passed you by that you kind of wish
you taken part in maybe you've
collaborated with a lot of people some
of the best you know in the plane I
would have to say not really because
even did we are the world which was
really wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know I've had about eight
top-ten records when I walked in that
studio and I thought that you're gonna
be glad to see me they're all it outsold
me ten times and you know you leave your
ego at the door and you go in and you
sing the parts you're given and it was
very humbling but very rewarding - we're
sure Kenny will feel even more humbled
next week when his famous friends pay
tribute to the icon at the all in for
the gambler Kenny Rogers farewell
concert celebration the evening will
feature a star-studded lineup including
Reba McEntire Lady Antebellum Lionel
Richie Chris Stapleton and yes Dolly
Parton what does her friendship meant to
you oh it's been great thing about Dolly
is she has never unless you make her mad
and I've never done that
she always everything she says comes
from so you have to take it that way she
can say the most bizarre things and she
does and if you remember they came from
love you can't be upset how are you
feeling right now a week away from an
event like just a few days away from I'm
excited because I don't really know
what's gonna happen
yeah I don't know who's gonna be there
for sure who's gonna sing what so that's
exciting for me to be still confused
we know there's there's a pretty
impressive guest list already it's gonna
be fun for me because I'm gonna sit on
stage with my wife and the good boys are
be in the front row and we're gonna
listen to people do my music and I've
always loved that no that's pretty great
it's got to be a little bit surreal to
hear that stuff it is yeah but I will
tell you this time and it's time for me
to move on